[Music]
you have
super fans and they just uh they love
you they're obsessed with you and they
there's a website where they put your
head on other celebrities bodies yeah
it's become
quite popular i thought we'd take uh we
have meetings at bus stops yeah i can
imagine where you talk about your poster
uh here they have you uh this is these
are all real they've made them not us
this is you as han solo which i thought
was quite good
here you are as elvis that they put this
up
and then i look i this was great this
next one is oprah and uh
you have creative fans
uh
i encourage you to follow that and that
seems like uh
i'd get that on a daily
i could look at those all day
you know maybe putting those pictures up
a regular part of our show no he just
means in our private time look at photos
of him
should give everyone in the audience
like a calendar with those things those
are fantastic weren't those great
wouldn't you pay
i'm sorry that's not going to happen by
the way
wouldn't you pay top did pay top dollar
for something like that yeah i mean
that's really one of the great
compliments i think i've ever received
that uh putting my face on the
oprah
you live a blessed life